NARRATOR: "We hold
these truths to be
self-evident that all men,
and women, are created equal."
No, that's not the
Declaration of Independence.
It's actually from the
Declaration of Sentiments,
a document signed at the first
ever Women's Rights Convention
in 1848.
Back then, women in the US
weren't allowed to do a lot
of things men were, like vote.
And it would take them
another 70 years to be
granted that fundamental right.
Why?
Well, many thought encouraging
women's involvement in politics
would undermine society.
The prospect of women voting
was threatening to the white men
who held power.
In 1848, Elizabeth Cady
Stanton and Lucretia Mott
decided to organize
factions across the country
that were campaigning for
suffrage or the right to vote.
The convention at
Seneca Falls, New York
addressed women's
rights and inspired
other conventions and meetings.
Stanton considered
it the beginning
of the women's rights movement.
After the Civil War,
the 15th Amendment
was introduced, which
would give black men,
but not women of any
color, the right to vote.
Suffragists were split.
Stanton and Susan B. Anthony
opposed the amendment,
objecting to the
exclusion of women.
They formed the National
Women's Suffrage Association,
hoping to pass a constitutional
amendment that included women.
Others, like abolitionists
Lucy Stone and Henry Blackwell
supported the 15th Amendment.
They founded the American
Women's Suffrage Association
and lobbied for the women's
right to vote on a state level
instead of through a
national amendment.
The 15th Amendment
was ratified in 1870.
Black men could vote,
but women still couldn't.
In 1878, a women's
suffrage amendment
penned by Susan B. Anthony was
finally proposed in Congress.
But it was defeated on
the Senate floor in 1887.
In 1890, the separate
suffrage movements
merged, opting to
tackle suffrage
by state in the wake of the
federal Amendment's defeat.
Within six years, Colorado,
Utah, and Idaho granted
women the right to vote.
Wyoming had already
done it in 1869.
Around the same time,
the National Association
of Colored Women was formed,
bringing together more than 100
black women's clubs.
It included leaders Mary Church
Terrell, Josephine Silone
Yates, and Anna Julia Cooper.
By the turn of the 20th century,
the women's suffrage movement
had gained renewed momentum.
Parades, marches,
and pickets drew
great attention to the cause.
Between 1910 and 1918, a number
of states and territories
expanded voting rights to women.
In 1912, 15,000 suffrage
supporters took to the streets
of New York City.
But as women's
political power grew,
so did the danger they faced.
In 1913, on the eve of President
Woodrow Wilson's inauguration,
hundreds of women were
injured in a massive suffrage
parade in the nation's capital.
In November of 1917, 33
suffragists were arrested
outside the White House.
The women were clubbed, beaten,
and tortured by prison guards
at the Occoquan Workhouse.
One of the movement's
leaders, Alice Paul,
founder of what became the
National Woman's Party,
was placed in
solitary confinement
in order to break her will
and undermine her credibility.
But press coverage of
the women's treatment
increased sympathy
for their plight.
And in 1918, Representative
Jeannette Rankin,
the first woman in Congress,
opened congressional debate on
a woman's suffrage amendment.
The resolution failed.
In 1918,
President Wilson also came
out in favor of suffrage,
declaring it was needed
as a war measure.
Wilson argued that women had
been providing vital roles
during World War I
and that their votes
should be counted
in order to make
the world safe for democracy.
Finally, in 1919, the Federal
Women's Suffrage Amendment,
the same one written by Susan
B. Anthony back in 1878,
was passed by the
House and the Senate.
And on August 26, 1920,
the 19th Amendment
was officially incorporated
into the US Constitution,
prohibiting denying the vote to
a US citizen based on gender,
although states could
still deny voting
rights based on other things.
It would take another four
years for Native American women
and men to get the right to
vote and more than 30 years
before major restrictions were
lifted on Asian-American voting
rights.